Democratic presidential hopeful Mike
Bloomberg is facing new attacks from
rivals on what they see as one of his
biggest vulnerabilities the former
Republican mayor of New York City is
trying to rally support after being hit
hard for backing police stop and frisk
policies in the past and for recently
revealed comments on mortgage lending to
black homeowners chief Washington
correspondent major Garrett is with us
major
what are these attacks happening right
now because the race is intensifying and
after 10 million 10 mins of millions of
dollar scuse me and TV and digital ads
and rising poll numbers this week it's
fair to say Mike Bloomberg vaulted from
curiosity to threat which means he
became a target of opposition research
and campaign Barb's a Bloomberg's effect
on the other Democratic candidates is
all too real voters are genuinely tuning
in that means scrutiny and criticism
aplenty the most important job I'm gonna
have is to defeat Donald Trump this
November at multiple events in Houston
in North Carolina Michael Bloomberg
continued aggressive attacks on
President Trump we know the con game
Donald Trump plays he's a one-trick pony
as Democratic rivals turned their fire
on Bloomberg for the first time I don't
think you can buy an election Bloomberg
apologized for a support of stop and
frisk policies to fight crime in New
York I know I can't change history but
what I can do is learn from my mistakes
and use those lessons to do right by
black and brown communities who have
suffered senator Elizabeth Warren coming
off disappointing losses in Iowa New
Hampshire pounced on Bloomberg's 2008
remarks that attributed some of the
mortgage crisis to a rollback of
redlining Congress got involved local
elected officials as well and said oh
that's not fair these people should be
able to get credit Warren said Bloomberg
needed a quote refresher on the racist
legacy of redlining
a systematic effort to deny minorities
access to among other things home loans
that crisis would not have been averted
if the banks had been able to be bigger
cysts and anyone who thinks that should
not be the leader of our party other
Democrats are demanding the former New
York City Mayor appear on the debate
stage and in their word stop ducking
voters with the next debate in Las Vegas
just days away Bloomberg would only need
to hit 10% in one more Democratic
National Committee approved
national poll to qualify all right major
garrett force thank you